hi guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about restless legs
syndrome
I had this condition in my 20s it drove
me crazy I would get up in the middle of
night and pound my legs to go run around
the block to try to get this energy out
little did I know it's actually very
easy to fix there's two prime primary
causes to this number one there's a
condition called lactic acidosis that
you may have and that is just a buildup
of lactic acid that deprives the muscle
of oxygen and there's a lot of restless
quivering and shaking and a feeling of
electricity in your legs and other
muscles as well so if this is the case
you just simply need vitamin b1 but I
like to get it from nutritional use
because most to be one that you buy is
synthetic the synthetic will still work
but you don't want to take it short long
term just may be short term but this is
a b1 deficiency and it works like within
a day okay so this is the more likely
cause and this is an electrolyte
imbalance with a potassium deficiency
okay now you need a lot of potassium
every day you need like 4700 milligrams
one banana is 300 milligrams you need
4700 now how many times is 300 go into
4700 a lot was it 14 to 15 times so
bananas aren't going to cut it so the
reason why you're deficient in potassium
there's three reasons one is you're not
consuming enough vegetable okay if you
did you get 2 potassium number 2 maybe
your stomach is not strong enough as far
as the acid if you're in the anti acid
medication well then you don't have the
correct pH to pull them that potassium
because what causes acid reflux is a
lack of acid so you want to take apple
cider vinegar or an acid or betaine
hydrochloride to be able to absorb and
get rid of the acid reflux so you can
absorb minerals in general so that's
just a side note of a lot of people that
have this problem don't even know it's
connected to lack of absorption
okay so we have lack of dietary
potassium number two we have the
stomach's not absorbing because it's not
acid enough number three you have a
blood sugar issue
could be hypoglycemia could be insulin
resistance it could be diabetes all
three conditions you have a state where
the insulin is not working and it's not
insulin controls potassium absorption so
if you don't have the facility to even
absorb potassium itself you can get
restless leg syndrome so I put a link
down below just to if you have blood
sugar issues you crave sweets or you're
tired after you eat or you could load it
after you eat or you're not fast enough
to you eat or you crave whatever carbs
then you need to watch that video okay
so you can fix that but taking potassium
will correct this so you want to
increase the vegetable but as an
immediate thing you can do is go to the
health food store go to Amazon and order
some potassium now the problem most
people do is when they order this they
don't realize that you can really only
order this in Nunda in milligrams so you
need 4700 milligrams so you don't have
like 100 like a lot of pills every
single day right that's not going to be
workable so get the powder and get
potassium citrate okay and then what you
can do is dissolve it and do like maybe
700 milligrams in some solution that's I
mean and then do another 700 like maybe
a couple hours later another 700 look so
spread it out slowly through the day do
this for two days watch your legs it'll
just like feel so much better okay and
then post your comments below so I hope
that helped but it's totally an
unnecessary condition you don't have to
take drugs and thank you for so much for
watching